foreign
[Music]
to be that big uh genius still there was
some capablanca-like quality in the way
that he made chess look very simple so
I'm gonna give him a 7 out of 10. uh his
games in themselves were entertaining
because he always played for a win even
though they weren't always exciting in
terms of new ideas he gets in he gets an
eight here I would say he scores very
highly both in terms of opening ideas
General ideas about the game and
everything that's around Fisher is
influenced chess greatly he's gonna get
the nine here and then in terms of
Sanity while he was world champion I
think he was still reasonably
well-rounded so he gets a four here